ok vous êtes engagés dans bien plus
qu'un combat contre la peine et la
souffrance des ukrainiens nous sommes
dans une nouvelle phase votre génération
est à un tournant toutes les quatre ou
cinq générations des changements
fondamentaux s'opère le nom ne sera plus
pareil pas à cause de l'ukraine d'ici 10
à 15 ans nos structures
organisationnelles vont changer la
question est qu'est-ce qui va prévaloir
les démocraties et les valeurs que nous
partageons où les autocraties
voilà pour cet hommage de joe biden le
président américain devant des soldats
américains dans l'est de pologne de la
pologne je me tourne vers vous gauthier
rybinski bonjour est ce qu il veut
montrer le président américain se
rendant comme ça dans l'est de la
pologne en rencontrant le président
polonais bon d'abord se rendre en
pologne et plus particulièrement à
rzeszow là où sont stationnés les
soldats américains c'est à cent
kilomètres de la frontière ukrainienne
et à 180km de vifs dont on connaît la
lahb la position centrale dans
effectivement l'ouest du pays donc c'est
un signe de soutien mais vous avez
remarqué un signe de soutien aussi aux
soldats américains qui sont stationnés
là vous avez remarqué que le discours va
plus loin il dit il s'agit de savoir si
ce sera la démocratie ou l'autocratie
très bien le problème c'est que en
échange de quoi il ne promet rien c'est
à dire qu'il ne parle de rien un combat
comme celui là qui consiste à défendre
la démocratie contre l'autocratie basse
ça requiert un certain nombre de choses
qui ne sont pas là et là on est devant
la énième preuve d'ambiguïté de
l'occident c'est à dire affirmé un
certain nombre de choses dira notamment
à la russie de vladimir poutine que les
choses ne se passeront pas comme lui le
l'autocrate poutine le veut et mais quoi
quoi d'autre quoi d'autre si ce n'est
que est d'ailleurs presque
involontairement joe biden le dit il ne
s'agit pas que de l'ukraine et oui c'est
ça le problème c'est que on a le
sentiment parfois que les responsables
occidentaux passent au delà de cette
crise de cette guerre pour dire on verra
plus tard on sera plus ferme mais si on
n'est pas faire maintenant avec
l'ukraine comment l'être ultérieurement
et voilà le la la difficulté parce que
ce discours est en contradiction avec
par exemple le fait que
l'otan que dominent les américains
n'interviendra pas sauf s'il y avait
effectivement un
une attaque indirecte ou non directs ou
direct plutôt des de la part de
l'artillerie russe vers un pays comme la
pologne mais tout cela est très
hypothétique et pendant ce temps là la
guerre en ukraine se poursuit donc voila
c'était c'est intéressant de par ce que
joe boyd et n'diaye c'est intéressant
aussi de parce qu'il ne fait pas est-ce
que ses alliés ne font pas